bom eu vou falar sobre internet do
futuro
a internet hoje é sem dúvida uma das
mais importantes infra-estruturas da
humanidade
ela mudou defesa forma como a gente se
comunica trabalha e até mesmo se diverte
esse evento aqui é um exemplo de como a
internet é importante ela é justamente
permitir a divulgação de novas idéias
pelo mundo inteiro
ela alcançou escalas fenomenais como
mostra a figura que é uma patologia
simplificada seja um desenho
simplificado da estrutura da internet
hoje é muito além do que imaginava os
projetistas da rede nessa rede
ela é muito importante para todos os
setores da economia inclusive para o
setor de serviços que é hoje mais
importante proibidos para ir dos países
desenvolvidos no brasil também se
encontra em desenvolvimento e que se
encontra nessa estatística então
internet é uma estrutura extremamente
importante para a economia hoje a sua
arquitetura ela é composta de centenas
de tecnologias protocolos que a gente
chama que são arranjos que permite a
comunicação entre máquinas né
são chamados protocolos e esses
protocolos eles cooperam entre si de
trabalho em conjunto interroperam a
gente diz é de uma forma muito muito
complexa e isso tem sido acrescentado
eles têm sido acrescentados à
arquitetura né
durante décadas e sempre de forma
incremental ou seja novas ideias novos
usos aparecem na internet
e esses protocolos vão sendo
acrescentado é sempre incrementalmente
só que essa essa abordagem ela tem
alguns problemas
algumas limitações por exemplo novas
tecnologias têm que viver com os
limitações e imperfeições e com a
complexidade das anteriores por mais
mirabolante que seja uma nova idéia ela
tem que conviver com décadas de trabalho
incremental já existentes na internet
ah e também internet foi desenhado em
uma época em que os computadores eram
fixas como esse que tá mostrando ali né
hoje a maior parte dos computadores na
internet são móveis
e na época também que a internet foi
desenhada a segurança era o caso
sempre né a internet ficava em
universidades e não havia problemas de
segurança
só que a realidade hoje é bastante
diferente e as pessoas estão à medida
que cada vez mais usam a internet se
dando por conta desses problemas e as
notícias sobre problemas e limitações da
internet estão cada vez mais presentes
na mídia então problemas como é quem
está atacando o meu computador se vocês
olharem o registro de ataques das
máquinas vocês vão ver que toda hora tem
gente tentando atacar sua máquina
outro problema será que a informação que
eu busquei na internet será que o
programa de computador que busca na
internet é aquele mesmo que eu quero
será que não há uma coisa embutido nele
ou será que não foi trocado quando
divulgou a informação na internet será
que ela vai parar nas mãos erradas né e
então são questões que está todo mundo
se perguntando hoje os terminais hoje
são todos os móveis praticamente a maior
parte móvel já né
e aí então que acontece quando o povo
esse terminal eu perco a conexão é um
aplicativo para preciso reiniciar tudo
né
se a gente ficar se envolvendo com o
terminal isso acontece o tempo todo é o
número que esse computador usa neoton
chama de endereço
ele também troca o tempo todo certo
então não é possível rastrear a onde as
pessoas tiveram que máquinas elas usaram
e que números elas usar os computadores
também a outra coisa esse trabalho
incremental desde décadas de trabalho
incremental de novos protocolos sendo
acrescentados muitas arestas ficaram
então hoje a gente tem um problema de de
muita carga muito controle é muito
controle pra pouca informação útil que
transita na internet
o resultado desse incremento desse
desenho incremental tô falando isso
explica um pouco porque a internet é tão
lenta às vezes a gente tem até uma boa
conexão mas as coisas não acontecem
eu tenho muito controle sendo disparadas
o tempo todo é porque eu não posso ter
10 e interfaces de rede no terminal e me
mover com essas dessa interface sem
perder a conexão é uma coisa
interessante que hoje fica bastante
fazer né a internet então a preocupados
com essa realidade é no mundo inteiro
centenas de projetos surgiram para
redesenhar o repensar na internet são
chamados projetos de internet do futuro
ii
nesse contexto nós temos o nosso
trabalho que é um projeto de pesquisa
mas também é um sonho foi apresentado
hoje que o evento
ele é um sonho porque nós enxergamos e
nós ficamos muito contentes em poder
investir nosso tempo nesse projeto
nesse trabalho e e realmente a acho que
a gente tenha obtido aí é grande
satisfação resposta que se diverte muito
com isso e já temos um protótipo
implementado no laboratório é mostrando
que essas idéias funciona então com o
que seria uma arquitetura da internet
feita com a nova gente e que benefícios
trabalhistas pessoas hoje e daqui pra
frente
bom hoje na internet é nós temos uma
questão importante que a questão das
notas dos nomes não é que é um nome você
todo mundo sabe o seu nome sabe o nome
de um monte de coisa a mais na internet
ela só conhece o protocolo só conhecem
os nomes dos computadores dos domínios
dos sites ou seja alguns nomes somente
estão na internet
mas o que a gente quer como a sociedade
colocar na internet tudo mas nós
queremos colocar tudo na internet
na internet a estrutura então líder com
alguns poucos nomes somente então se a
gente for redesenhar a internet é uma
coisa interessante incluir os nomes em
linguagem natural seja uma vez que
normalmente a gente utiliza o nome das
pessoas nomeadas das ruas das cidades em
várias línguas né
agora a máquina ela precisa de uma
referência não vai utilizar esse nome é
é às vezes cobra muito grande então às
vezes ele é ambígua então a máquina
precisa de uma referência a isso juntam
os nomes chamados nome saltou
certificável
eles são gerados a partir do padrão da
existência
por exemplo você tem uma impressão
digital
então a partir dessa impressão digital
passando por um algoritmo você pode
gerar um nome chamado auto certificável
ou seja toda vez que você colocar o dedo
na máquina né vai se obter um padrão de
impressão digital ea partir daí um nome
que é sempre o mesmo você pode votar
quantas vezes quiser
a menos que você troca de ideli vai
gerar o mesmo padrão
as máquinas também têm padrões né na
hora que o chip é construído na hora que
os processadores são integradas as
memórias e os nossos arquivos também têm
padrões então a nova internet que tire
vantagem desses padrões e coloque esses
nomes linguagem de máquina né
ela permite fazer uma coisa bastante
interessante que é o seguinte uma rede
de relacionamentos de nomes é o tema do
nosso nosso evento aqui é conectando
idéias né pois idéias são expressas por
nomes e uma rede de relacionamentos nada
mais é do que uma grande rede de nomes
conectados o de idéias conectadas
hoje os protocolos da internet não
entende isso não consegue entender a
relação entre as coisas é nome sempre
coisas com uma arquitetura que captura
isso a gente conseguir então criar redes
de relacionamentos conectar nomes
conectar idéias ea internet entenderia
isso e seria bastante útil pra o resto é
que eu vou falar agora aqui primeiro
identificar o alvo da comunicação não é
como é que você identifica o alvo do da
comunicação hoje se você quer um
determinado site na internet você tem
que digitar um endereço que ele tá né
e aí a rede vai trazer a informação que
estava pois você tem que dizer onde está
para poder trazer estar com esses nomes
você pode simplesmente dizer qual é a
informação que você quer e não há onde
ela se encontra onde se encontra na
porta de trás a última versão do jornal
e traz do lugar mais próximo que tivesse
essa cópia dessa informação
mas hoje infelizmente a gente não
consegue fazer isso há que dizer o
endereço do local onde está a informação
para poder trazer
então a utilização dos nomes permite
justamente apontar o alvo de todas as
coisas nomeadas podem ser alvo da
comunicação os nossos serviços
os nossos nossas informações os nossos
programas e esses há nomes também
permite relacionar por exemplo elevar
isso aqui ele está associado antônio
aqui né então os nomes permite também
encontrar as coisas por exemplo todos
vocês têm nomes aqui e vocês estão
dentro de seu território que tem o nome
de uma cidade que tem um nome
então a gente pode localizá los a partir
desses nomes a internet não consegue
capturar isso não ela foi desenvolvida
quando isso é praticamente impossível de
ser feito mas hoje é possível de ser
feito então novas internet podem ter
esse tipo de recurso
os serviços os serviços programas
aplicativos é eles trabalham você dar
dois cliques ele abre faz o serviço dele
isolado qualquer ideia com essa idéia
para novas arquiteturas serviço se
descobre quando você liga o programa ele
descobre tem alguém aí que faz sentido
eu cooperará tem alguém que quer
trabalhar comigo
por exemplo eu tenho aqui três devices
uma câmera né
uma câmera 2 e um repositório de fotos
então esse programa que quando ele liga
e diz olha eu tenho foto antônio como
ele sabe bom na hora que foi instalado
então tem uma relação com o nome da
pessoa a quem também tem fotos de
antônio e esse cara caramba sou um
repositório de fotos de antônio
vamos trabalhar junto e aí acontece a
negociação
isso não existe esporte para esse tipo
de coisa hoje na internet
então os programas descobrem um
negocinho e passa a trabalhar juntos só
em que acontece a troca de informação
naturalmente qual é o benefício que traz
rede de confiança os serviços trabalham
numa rede confiável então um novo
serviço vai ter que ganhar confiança
primeiro pra poder ser usado em conjunto
com outros e sempre relacionado às
pessoas ao ser humano
a linguagem é só por último depois que
todo mundo já se conhece estar de acordo
é que acontece a troca de informação tão
a
a gente fica muito mais segura né existe
uma preocupação com a privacidade e isso
não é o caso atual da atual
implementação
toda informação pode ser rastreada desde
a foto o programa que manipulou o
computador até a pessoa né então a para
quem tem autorizado a ver todas as
relações são transparentes
então acontece um aumento da segurança
porque as pessoas podem ver rastrear as
coisas
qual foi a máquina que processa foto
como foi a da onde que veio verificar a
proveniência e vários outros aspectos
que melhora a segurança os serviços
verificam né
eu posso confiar nesses serviços possa
então faz parte da rede de confiança
agora ou não não posso confiar então
esquece não vou trocar informação com
você
outro aspecto modelo de comunicação hoje
o transmissor que envia o receptor
recebe não tem recebe tudo certo na
internet corrente e essa é uma das
minhas origens o que a gente tem
problema que é o spam você recebe meio
de gente que você não conhece o conteúdo
que você não sabe de quem são como que
seria no futuro o transmissor pública o
receptor assina se quiser se fizer parte
da rede de confiança
se for identificado corretamente o que é
meu amigo que mandou então assina esse
conteúdo
isso melhora muito ao muitos dos
problemas que a gente tem hoje e seria
provavelmente o fim do spam mobilidade
como é que é hoje quando um novo
terminal de uma rede para outra todos os
números mudam né
ou seja mudou de rede é como se fosse
outro dispositivo não é possível
relacionar com onde estava antes rapel
de rastreabilidade
além do que esses números são facilmente
manipuláveis
então não existe raça verdade não existe
uma identificação das fontes né
como seria o futuro o nome do
dispositivo não muda a venda
permanece o mesmo o que muda só onde ele
se encontra
então você pode mudar mudar uma
dispositivo de lugar se pode mudar os
serviços de lugar e pode mudar os
conteúdos lugar o nome deles nunca muda
assim como seu nome não muda quando você
se move você mudar seu nome eu tenho que
fazer um registro um processo legal né
então uso desses nomes melhorem muito o
que a gente tem hoje na internet
enquanto os dispositivos vão ver na
internet daqui 20 anos esse é outro
aspecto importante que a gente precisa
considerar novas arquiteturas né
uma galáxia de dispositivos não existe
bilhões de dispositivos não existe
remédio
então me imaginar todo esse processo
manual nesse processo que não tem
transparência que sofre de de lacunas de
segurança e privacidade como é que vai
ficar quando tiver bilhões de
dispositivos a mais atraente
basta um desses dispositivos publicar
uma coisa no twitter que não devia
pronto comprometeu a privacidade de uma
pessoa por exemplo agora já saiu uma
falta é que quando nem faz xixi ea falta
no twitter a mãe já viu um negócio
desses
pois é isso é só o começo imagina se
você tiver microrrobôs mandando e
desmandando twitter por pra todo mundo
coisas que não deve
então é um exemplo de que nós vamos ter
bilhões de dispositivos e vai desafiar o
modelo atual está vai desafiar muito o
modelo atual não existe mais internet
sem essas coisas já era internet a
partir de agora o número de terminais de
coisas vai aumentar muito
então as coisas não são mais a sessão
vão se tornar regra daqui a pouco a
internet do futuro ea internet coisa é a
mesma coisa é não tem diferença entre as
duas
nós temos cinco sentidos né
vocês estão usando alguns agora como
quando os sentidos vai ter uma internet
de coisas
milhares de sentidos sem pressão
temperatura uso do espectro
eletromagnético energia água todas as
coisas do mundo físico podem ser
monitoradas por esses sentidos né
e também a internet com essas com essa
para com esses artefatos podem alterar o
mundo físico interagir com o mundo
físico
chávez mudar a forma como as coisas no
mundo físico são feitas então é porque
isso serve a gente primeiro se todas as
coisas do mundo físico vão estar sendo é
trazidas pela internet
a internet pode de fato nos ajudar
através desses serviços confiáveis que
estava falando recém que se descobrem
que que negociam é que se auto organizam
para resolver objetivos como a
transferência de fotos por exemplo
todas essas coisas trabalhando em
conjunto elas vão poder de fato nos
ajudar muito né
além do que a internet atual está nos
ajudando a resolver os problemas do
nosso século ou por exemplo o uso da
energia há a preocupação com o meio
ambiente a água o uso do recurso público
porque esse sim esse ambiente de
interação mundo físico mundo virtual vai
criar a informação é os sentidos para
que a gente crie significado né
a partir do significado serviços passam
a se auto organizar e nos ajudar de fato
a melhorar o uso desses recursos
enfim nos tornarmos melhores mais bem
relacionados com o meio ambiente é usar
melhor os recursos que a gente tem né
mas quem vai gerenciar esses
dispositivos então é como foi falado
durante evento hoje várias vezes é todo
mundo tem um lado positivo tem um lado
negativo sempre né
então quem vai gerenciar vocês vão
gerenciar a gente vai gerenciar imagina
que tenha é 2 mil dispositivos na sua
casa você vai gerenciar eles manualmente
classificando assim como você verifica
hoje seu terminal celular né vai ficar
entrando em cada um para 30 fazendo não
é a gente vai precisar de programas e
serviços confiáveis que gerencia essas
coisas que eu estou chamando aqueles
dispositivos sociais dispositivos social
é um dispositivo que tem um
representante de software serviço
confiável que vai então se auto
organizar descobrir outras outras coisas
outros serviços ea partir daí auto
organizar e
melhor utilizar o mundo físico melhor
utilizar os próprios recursos de
software
tudo isso de forma mais confiável usando
os nomes sabendo exatamente o nome de
cada coisa que está envolvida no
processo
tenho duas mensagens finais a primeira é
o seguinte eu acredito sim que com a
gente com que a gente tem hoje
tecnologia a gente pode de fato criar
novas arquiteturas na internet que tirem
proveito desse ambiente tecnológico
atual e que nos ajudem ainda mais
resolver os problemas da humanidade
então acredito bastante na nova genes
acredito que é possível sim inovar e
criar novas arquiteturas para internet
ea minha segunda mensagem é a seguinte é
hoje se vocês olharem da república na
casa de vocês nas repúblicas de
estudantes de engenharia em todas as
casas em geral a quantidade de
computadores está aumentando muito a
república sakineh santa rita deve haver
aí 4 10 computadores
contando os smartphones gente isso é
muito mais do que havia à época em que
foi feita a internet atual atestar a
internet atual era necessário
supercomputadores e uma parafernália que
só via nas universidades
hoje vocês têm na república de vocês
isso então fica aí a mensagem final todo
mundo pode hoje inovar fazer a pesquisa
propor novas arquiteturas na internet e
nos ajudará a criar essa nova
arquitetura das novas arquiteturas
convergentes universais de informação
obrigado